your show is the first show that I've
ever watched on kwibi survive and it's
beautiful it's really well done
it's it's fantastic oh thank you really
proud of this we're really proud of it I
mean I kind of just just getting around
to watch it I haven't watched it oh yeah
in fact I don't think they sent me the
last episode so I'm wondering what's
gonna happen you have been drinking a
lot that's not not true on on that movie
we were shooting in the Dolomites in
Italy and towards the end of the shoot
it's just wading through like three feet
of snow got the best got the best of us
so we ended up we would just kind of go
and and there were like little cabins
little stations for the gondolas and so
we would just go there and drink mulled
wine coffee cups all day I haven't seen
this prep but you fight wolves in
episode of the show was that I mean this
is you've had experience with wolves
before I'm gay were you working with the
same wolves were you like oh hey guys
how are you how's it fashion actually
yeah we were working with the people who
provided the wolves for Game of Thrones
oh really same people yeah the same the
same people so it was actually quite
horrible because you know in Game of
Thrones like the wolves are our pets are
like a our soul mates kind of and and on
this I have to basically like fight a
wolf and try and kill the thing yeah and
so I found it to be quite symbolic
actually you know like Game of Thrones
it just ended so I was you know
figuratively killing the wolf and ending
my career yes killing the the that part
of that part is over now that part is
over it was wonderful but now the
analogy is the wolf must die
yes exactly I just the idea of you being
reunited with a war
that you had worked with before and like
smoking a cigarette like Sophie we have
a clip here from survived which we're
going to show right now this is with
your co-star our Corey Hawken is that
right yes Corey Hawkins you guys are
stuck on the edge of a cliff I think in
this clip yeah we're stuck on the edge
of the cliff and there's no other way
down but to jump but to jump yes another
good metaphor for many things let's take
a look at that clip now huh
[Music]
and we're back thank you what a great
clip wasn't that a great clip it was
we'll add that later I'm being honest
with my audience we didn't see the clip
right now that was good acting on your
part you too we should do no no you're
doing really well and you do not want to
do get me into the movies with you
you're just stay away from me as an
actor look out for survive on kwibi it's
really good and this is the perfect time
to be watching something like this great
new show in 10-minute installments and
if not now when
exactly and you know what it is really
nice to talk to you nice to talk to you
I'm so happy for all the good things
that are happening in your life and that
you're staying well and enjoying the
quarantine you too
I mean I hope you're enjoying the
quarantine but I love coming on your
show I love seeing you you're one of my
favorites okay we'll just say don't say
one open it I can't say favorite though
because I think that if I ever go on
another show they'll pull me out for I
know those other people and they're very
very bitter yeah
not like me hey Sophie thank you so much
be well
stay safe my best to Jo and enjoy enjoy
your 80s music marathon I'll try to and
if you need anything I'll pick it up for
you and drive over to where you are and
throw it through your window thanks so
much please do okay once they say